sound effects make movies movies but
there's a bit of sausage making going on
here sometimes you're better off not
knowing where those sounds originated so
start banging your coconut shells
together as we gallop through the
secrets behind some of the most bizarre
sound effects in recent movie history
Star Wars sound designer ben burtt is
viewed as a legend in movie production
circles for his sound effect creation
methods and with four Oscars to his name
on beloved productions such as ET and
the Indiana Jones series it's no
surprise the next time you or one of
your friends swings an invisible
lightsaber in an imaginary battle just
remember who came up with that unique
swoosh sound as clumsy or random as a
blaster an elegant weapon but a more
civilized age working on the 1977 space
fantasy classic Burtt found an old film
projector and blended its sound with an
old TV to create the distinctive
lightsaber noise just sat there and idle
made a wonderful humming sound and would
slowly change in pitch however even a
maestro like Bert needed a touch of luck
and the whirling element of the
lightsaber sound was discovered
completely by accident
he managed to capture the iconic sound
by thrusting a shotgun microphone back
and forth in front of a speaker the
inventive sound designer for James
Cameron's 102 million dollar masterpiece
Terminator 2 Judgment Day came up with
some frugal and unusual methods to make
the film sound as good as it looked the
special effects for the film were
spectacularly groundbreaking and ate up
a large portion of the den recorded
budget
this makes Gary rides from Achievement
swith the sound effects budget all the
more impressive amazingly an everyday
item played a key role in completing one
of the film's coolest scenes Robert
Patrick ste 1000 is chasing John and
Sarah Connor through a mental asylum but
a row of jail bars appear to block him
but he's liquid metal so he just goes
right through
[Music]
Rydstrom revealed that he came up with a
very cost-effective way to create the
sound he turned a dog food can upside
down and slowly ease the congealed food
out the quality of Rydstrom 'he's
methods was matched only by his
creativity which yielded another
unexpected and comical money-saver for
terminator 2 by submerging a microphone
wrapped in a condom into a thick flour
water mix and then blowing dust off into
it he was able to create the perfect
sound for the t1000 shape-shifting
abilities beneath the mines of moria
lives the terrifying fire demon known as
the Balrog which shows up just in time
to ruin the day for Frodo and his
friends in the Fellowship of the Ring
the sound of that blood-chilling roar
was achieved by dragging a concrete
block slowly across a wooden floor while
horses and donkeys were layered in to
fill out the sound it was the work of
sound designer David farmer who also
created the sound of Moria orcs after a
visit to a Marine Mammal Center
he told Empire it was the time of year
they had lots of baby elephant seals
there so we recorded ourselves
scrambling around wearing cleats for the
movement but the major signature sound
for them was the elephant seal pups
dinosaurs have been extinct for
thousands of years so obviously no one
really knows what they sounded like now
not even the people who worked on
Jurassic Park
although the finished product sounds
fitting in Jurassic Park it does make
you wonder how wrong filmmakers have
gotten when it comes to movies featuring
prehistoric creatures in a 1995
documentary director Steven Spielberg
told sound designer Gary rides from to
quote go make dinosaur sounds that don't
sound like Godzilla or Rodin what's
really fun to me sometimes is just
having something on a keyboard and
performing it almost like music and
wants a picture and giving it a try and
seeing how it work ride strums approach
was to find a creature that scientists
estimates existed close to the time of
dinosaurs tortoises the shelled
creatures did provide the right sound
fights but how it came about was both
strange and unforeseen Rydstrom sat
around for hours recording tortoises
while they made it
cover your ears kids does anyone know
what a giant rolling Boulder sounds like
as it bears down on you after a
booby-trap and an ancient temple has
been triggered
no but Raiders of the Lost Ark sound
designer ben burtt managed to creates a
pretty convincing approximation by using
an old Honda Civic on gravel road and we
just coasted down this road and as the
car accelerated it gave a sense of
gathering speed and that ended up being
really the basis for the giant boulder
to record the sound Burt had to hang out
the back window of the car with his boom
mic pointing down toward the tires does
that make him the Indiana Jones of sound
design maybe the web that shoots from
his wrists have saved spider-man on many
occasions but how do you decide on a
sound for such an unusual tool
[Music]
spider-man director Sam Raimi had high
standards when it came to what he wanted
and sound department veteran Charles
Mane's it is best to come up with
something unique initially there were
failed experiments with blow darts and
chemical rockets before the crack of a
bullwhip got the whole process started
with that first layer down the second
came from a very unexpected place
a feral cat that manes himself rescued
from the pound who would attack him
every time he tried to feed her and she
would spit and that spitting sound
actually was one of the principal
components for the actual shot it's
honestly amazing that putting an angry
cat in the sound design worked out so
well
that decision could have gone horribly
wrong
No
[Music]